shall we get started again
so
okay so before lunch we um
looked at
some uh
places of vocal circuits so specifically
those ones that that satisfy the
composability determinism and then you
saw you know a few different ways we
could maybe take a another problem model
and then compile them to do inference on
the cert using the circuits right
so all um
so I also want to talk a bit more about
uh other kinds of logical circuits that
have stronger properties that will later
let us actually compute Hardware queries
like the ones that were teased earlier
um including actually
um talking about probabilities of
logical events and so on
so
um some examples of starting from bdd's
binary decision diagrams
um and then if we say um in that bdd for
any path you can only have a variable
occurring once you can read once a
branching program like circuits would be
fpdds if you enforce the kind of
ordering of variables a total order on
all of the paths we have obdds used for
a lot in like verification and so on and
then
um kind of a generalized version we have
also uh some potential distance diagrams
which I'll get to the the properties
about it in a bit
um this is just to show you that often
we use this kind of
um
decision dag the representation for for
um bdds right like each of these being a
decision node saying you know if x is
true you go this way the f x x is false
you follow the dotted line
um you can kind of do a simple
translation into the circuit language
that we've seen so far using
um and then or Gates and and these are
these are equivalent
so you can kind of think of
um also bdds as uh kind of circuits with
uh different properties which I'll talk
about
um so for
STDs
um we're going to enforce essentially a
stronger kind of decomposability and
also a stronger notion of determinism
so um
so this is actually an example of an sdd
um so we have this property called
structured decomposability basically
meaning that how
um how the circuit partitions the
variables at every or gate is dictated
by this uh
binary tree called V3 right so it's just
a binary tree with with
variables associated with the leaves and
this is telling us
um how to decompose variables at every
anode
for instance
all of this I know that the very top
corresponds to this root of the vitri
so that
um you can see on the left side you have
variables L and K on the right side you
have variables p and a and that is true
for all these
anodes
and then this um of course happens for
for every end gate so now that the one
below here is is decomposing the
variables into
L on one side K on the other side
corresponding to this internal battery
node
and then I mentioned we'll also have a
stronger notion of determinism
so sometimes called Partition or strong
determinism
um
basically says that so it is we want
every or gate to be deterministic not
just deterministic but also
um deterministic specifically on the
um on the left child
of this sort of decision node
we have a pair of Oren and Gates you
want it to be
um deterministic specifically on on
these
uh left child so
um because
you know
um
this implies determinism but not every
deterministic circuit is going to be
strong deterministic what do you mean
the domestic on the left side so
basically
um essentially if you look at these
three three um
edges or
um these three three inputs
you want at most one of these to be
true for any any uh joint assignment
instead of just the inputs to the
um instead of just inputs the or gate
when you have decision nodes you
actually want
specifically the left child of the
decision
know to be deterministic
so for instance
um we could have determinism where
foreign input let's see
let's say um let's see let's see this
one evaluated through like let's say
this is red this is blue
right in that case this top node will
still be deterministic but then that
would violate strong determinism
I don't know if people are familiar with
fbds free right so uh
okay let me back from one more uh think
about that not a determinism the problem
is checking determinism is actually hard
you need to check that two four two
formulas are mutually exclusive and this
is uh probably going to be completed not
probably certainly couldn't be complete
yeah so correct me if I'm if I'm wrong
uh okay so we cannot check determinist
busy uh there is a trigger way to
enforce determinism this is what fpdgs
are doing namely for each or node there
is a single variable uh for which the
left chart is conjoined with a negation
the right child is conjoined with the
variable itself
so these two children can never be equal
through the same time because it's
variable controls uh determine it's
relaxes a little bit instead of
controlling over a single variable you
can control over multiple Expressions
which are the the left child of that end
node I think that is a progression that
I have in mind to to understand sdgs
yeah sorry yeah no no that's a that's a
great
um explanation so basically like we have
here decision nodes deciding based on a
single variable right so instead of a
single variable you could imagine
deciding based on some logical formula
so
[Music]
what first thing application
so um one
um
literally you can do I don't think it's
necessary because it's not necessary
what is this so what what is it is
giving that is that is not given by the
previous compilation oh okay yeah so um
I'll actually touch on on some
um query classes especially if we have a
lot of examples I'll let you go through
like probability inference
um so if
um in the in the beginning the queries
um you mentioned and include like
marginal map and just kind of doing you
know map over a marginal distribution
and some other like information Theory
occurrence which will actually produce
this problem okay sir when you say to
the idea is that they left children are
mutually exclusive but if they can be
arbitrary formula is it easier to check
that they are mutually exclusive because
when it's a single literal of course
it's scenario that it's music so that's
the right children being always empty
and then you will be back to the
previous situation so
well it's it's um I think checking
determinism to begin with is is hard
okay so also in the case of sdds yeah
it's also it's also hard so
um it's something you could enforce more
as a syntactic and like struct through a
property as you're compiling for example
okay
and then you know
so I think you can still check the
patients
right
yeah right but if in general you're
given the arbitrary circuit you're
trying to check
uh from determinism then at least as
hard as just checking determines it yeah
are they structured the STDs sorry yeah
okay so then you can control
effects
okay and then
um sorry connecting sdds to also
mentioned earlier on obdds
uh basically we can think I think this
already came up slightly so you can
think of you know sdds as a
generalization of
um obedience or obdis being a subset of
STDs basically that
um so these these two are equivalent
circuit
um
don't worry about this circles and boxes
here basically the circles mean or Gates
the boxes mean take product of or pick
um conjunction of these two okay
so this is a equivalent
to
um
this OBD and in particular any STD that
has or any OBD you can think of as sdd
having this kind of linear or right
linear to be precise uh V3
where you are always branching on one
variable on the left side
Okay so
where can we actually you know use this
right so I think this
question came up a couple times so
um one example that was teased earlier
is actually Computing the probability of
some logical events
for example this one where you have um
where you're asking okay what's the
probability of probably that there will
be traffic jam on on my my route to
campus the root given as some kind of
you know disjunction uh
over there being some you know traffic
jam in all the streets that that's um
yeah that's in your word okay
so this is kind of a simple example of a
logical formula but you could imagine
you know asking this kind of question of
given some um
some more more complicated kind of
logical formula what is the probability
um that that will be satisfied
and another example we saw was
um
I think you will talk about the gelato
and doing try to do like uh controlled
language generation where you're given
some like logical constraints that you
want to satisfy in your
um in in the generated language
so that is also kind of Computing this
you know probability of
um
well technically it's Computing the
probability of that forward living and
satisfied and also actually sampling
from that uh distribution okay
so how do we actually do this
now this is kind of our our first
example query where we're going to have
the two circuits involved so what we do
is is
for instance in this example when you
want to calculate the probability of
some logical event we're going to
compile that logical formula into a
logical circuit
and if
um this probability of distribution is
also given as a circuit we can actually
um compute this query attractively of
course given uh some structured
properties right
also this is kind of the first example
where your query
um size is not trivial uh you to Define
your query we're using a logical formula
or logical circuit
so now trackability means that your your
um you want to compute queries in
polynomial time in both the size of not
just your probabilistic circuit but also
your logical circuit defining your your
query
and so the um
properties that we need in this case is
going to be
um first smoothness
and this stronger notion of
decomposability admission
um structure decomposability
and then also on the logical circuit we
want determinism
um
to be satisfied as well
and particularly not only we want both
the probabilistic and logical circuits
to be structurally decomposable we
actually want them to
they actually want them to be um
structurally composable with respect to
the same V3
meaning you have two circuits that will
decompose variables in exactly the same
way
okay so how does
um how does the inference actually work
so
um similar idea like we we go from
um we start at the root of the circuit
and see how we can break the um break
the query down to queries on the inputs
or like input Gates or sub-circuits
um starting from the root all the way to
the leaf node
okay so let's start at the very top we
have um so basically we want to compute
this uh probability
here we go the probability of a logical
formula given by the circuit so we're
looking at these two nodes here okay so
we're looking at the pair of nodes here
and we know that this is smooth and The
Logical
um
or gate is smooth and also the
deterministic
so what that means is
um the actual
formula we want to compute
it's going to look like this so the
probability
um
decomposes into some of problems given
by the child notes right highlighted in
blue here
and then
and then this logical formula
um
it's just a disjunction of the formulas
given by the child now because this is
deterministic what we can say is the
probability of this disjunction is just
some of their probabilities right some
some of the pro um probability of the
small child logical functions
okay so what this
so what we what we've done here is is
taken
this query at the top and turned it into
a another you know weighted sum of
queries looking
um looking at every pair of
probabilistic circuit
um probably circuit uh child node and
The Logical circuit childhood okay
okay so now we pushed it down one layer
so what happens at
um product and end Gates
so here
um we said that they are both structured
decomposable with respect to the same V3
meaning
they both um so so they both break down
into product or conjunction of
um two functions
each depending on the same variable so
the left child
left one depends on the same variable as
the left child of the logical circuit
and then the right child of the
probability circuit depend on
um the same same variables as the right
child of the um of The Logical circuit
basically this probability of a formula
just decomposes into taking the product
of the probability of
each pair of nodes the the
um less Child Left children and then the
right children
so all we do is just keep doing this you
know from the um
from the root all the way down to the
leaves where at the at the leaf the
assumption is that you can for example
for instance just
um compute the probability of a single
single literal very easily
binding these together the um again the
dynamic programming algorithm is
basically
roughly at each layer because this is
you know structurally composable you can
think of every um
every layer of the circuit being
associated with kind of a layer of the
V3 so at every uh layer you look at all
pairs of probabilistic circuit node and
The Logical circuit node
compute
you know the probability of The Logical
event so compute compute this PR query
and then combine them using the formula
that I've just showed you in the in the
last couple slides
so again this gives us this single feed
forward evaluation that lets us compute
a probability of logical event
so um
in addition to the the pr query that I
just
talked about so there's some more
examples of of queries that you can
compute if you have structure
decomposability and
most of this also are strong determinism
so for instance if you have an sdd or
probabilistic version of sdd and you had
the right V3 you'll be able to compute
you know marginal map
split over this
um probably The Logical event
and also some information Theory queries
which I'll also talk a little more about
later
and some some operations as well right
so so far we've been talking about you
know answering uh queries Computing
probabilities on circuits what you can
also do is is you know combine two
circuits for instance in the in the
logic domain this is very natural to do
trying to like conjoin or disjoin
circuits you could do something similar
with
probabilistic circuit trying to like
multiply distributions and different
operators
which I'll also talk about some of those
operators later on
um but they they also require that you
have this structure decomposable
property
so so with this additional properties
there's a lot more uh query you can
answer
um tractably
so so that's why depending on what kind
of reasoning queries you would care
about at the end that would dictate your
your compilation language and when
you're compiling your probabilistic
model or some
you know CNF formula
you would decide what properties you
want to enforce based on what you want
to um do with the compiled circuit at
the end right
so that was kind of
um well the the earlier session before
lunch and and this one is combining you
know how probabilistic circuits or or
um related to logical circuits and and
how we can you know compile these
circuits to do inference
so next
I want to talk about you know how
um how the properties that give you this
trackability actually affect your your
circuit size right
since of course
um
trackability is is of course defined
with respect to the the size of the
circuit right we're saying okay you're
going to be linear timer or polynomial
uh time in the size of your circuit if
your circuit size blows up that
tractability isn't really meaningful
so we want to you know study
um how different properties affect the
size of your circuit
um she in this part of course there's a
lot of you know literature in studying
relative expressive efficiency or
sickness of different circuit families
I'll kind of give the few pointers
um and highlight some results but um I
won't go over the details too much but I
like to kind of give you pointers for
you to go and see um if you're if you're
interested and also
give some examples of like open problems
there
okay so let me um let's
let's first uh
formally Define what I mean by sickness
so uh we say
um a family of circuits and one is at
least as succinct as another family and
two
if you can take any circuit in the
second family
turn it into a circuit in the first one
without changing what function it
represents and um in in polynomial size
right
and here I kind of vaguely said function
this definition applies to The Logical
circuits
um probabilist probabilistic circuits
and and other same rings as well
basically if it's logical circuit we
talk about Boolean functions if it's
probabilistic circuit we're talking
about the likelihood function
okay
sorry I'm confused here by the direction
so um M1 you want to write M1 is less
than M2
so does it mean uh my interpretation
would be that every circuit in M1 can be
simulated by one and M2
no so if you think about
um
so if we say M1 is just the family of
all circuits right with no properties
um with no constraints
then that's
um clearly at least as succinct as any
other cell families right
and and in that case we can say you know
any any for example decomposable circuit
is a circuit so this direction is always
satisfying
how you would normally write a reduction
by analogy with uh computational the
computational model of circuits
shouldn't there be also some conditions
here about
uh the related to that because I am
concerned about for example
the subtleties that occur there when you
have the uniform families of circuits of
foreign
do you compute M1 from M2 I think that's
what done for example for some nuts but
more generally yeah this is not about
Computing it's just about the existence
right yeah yeah and um
we'll we'll bring me
um to characterize this values of
circuits based on the structure
properties and not so much about for
example like the primaries and like
arbitrary you know like the
organizations it can be
um in the circuit families also when
when I say A family of circuits
I'm mainly talking about circuits that
satisfy
properties x y and z
um and and also I'll later talk a little
more about you know is that the right
characterization
is the number of notes every note has
binary inputs
the size
hello I'm bounded fan now all right
okay is is this slide okay now
oh and just again
um mentioned this but yeah so this is
how we would write that M1 is at least
as succinctive uh and two and of course
if we want to write strictly more
succinct then the One Direction is true
but not the other
right so
this is kind of the the succinctness uh
map from uh another version and pure
Market's uh knowledge compilation map
that's
characterizing uh
relatives of sickness between these
families of circuits for example nnf is
all nnf circuits and this is saying it's
it's strictly more succinct than a dnnf
which is a decomposable nnf and so on
right and and here we get this um strict
the thickness ordering from from these
circuit families that we've seen so
um
decomposable NF to deterministic and
decomposable NF
um and then to fpdd OBD
um I won't go over like
all pairs here but just to kind of like
give an example of one of these you know
um strict separation
so if you're looking at so this is
saying taking a decomposable circuit and
then trying to make it uh deterministic
is hard
um
so a sort of conditional
hardness is is easy to show you can take
or is this any query that you can
compute with
um
with deterministic and decomposable
circuit but not with a decomposable
circuit
one example could be like trying to do
counting in in dnf which is
um
yeah which is which is which is going to
be a dnnf right
because it's you know because it's the
complete you can say it's decomposable
but then
counting on dnf is actually sharply hard
meaning you can't really
um you can't make it deterministic and
uh for normal time unless the polymer
hierarchy collapses
to get this kind of results
that would have some computational
aspects
for for upper bound sure but
it's kind of uh
there are like conflicting theorems that
say
electrons
and polymerpy collapses so it's probably
probably uses
yeah there are connections out there
from 9 to 4pm sorry
and then
also
more slightly more recently we also have
an example actually showing that this uh
separation can be proven without this
condition so there is actually an
exponential uh
um
I don't really like understand the
details of the proof um so I'll just
kind of mention that
how this you know
this whole
separation shown is is actually
excluding a connection between circuit
sizes and um multiple partition
communication complexity
and I believe uh Stephen mingle who is a
co-author on this paper I think he'll be
here at some point so if you're
interested do you happen to know that
our hope it's our whole functions do you
know what it is
um
just if you know what I mean
yeah I'm not I'm not really familiar
like with the intuition of the function
okay
[Music]
yeah I just know that it's like
something that's relevant in uh
communication complexity and it kind of
um basically some some results uh about
the sort of function and the hardness of
um the the um communication protocol
sort of implies this explanation lower
fund
okay
all right
um so one more one more example uh of
sort of success result between
um
between two families of circuits so
earlier I said that you know we saw that
obds are actually kind of subclass of
um
STDs right
basically every OBD you can think of it
as a sdd with a particular V3 meaning
um
STDs or at least as succinct as uh obds
and also
um again more more recently
we also now have actually a
unconditional exponential separation
between sdds and obdds
so again here
um all like refer refer you to this
paper for the details of the proof
basically
um he identified a sort of class of
Boolean functions that that will have a
cubic size STD but then
um
think that was
there was some kind of a
formatting errors that this is supposed
to say you know to the negative n of
course so basically um the function
will have obdds of
size that's exponential right
it kind of um so the intuition is that
the the
um sdd that lets or the V3 that lets you
get an sdd of this polynomial size looks
something like this in the case of for
uh variables
so if you basically the intuition is
that if you want to take this Victory
and then make it rightly right linear to
turn it into an
um turn it into an OBD you get this
exponential size blow up
so the fact that you can branch on
multiple branch of multiple variables
and not just one on the left side at all
times is actually very very useful when
you think about the circuit size
okay so
um because we're here to talk about you
know database and AI so here's here's a
slide I kind of stole from Dan and
Andy's
um tutorial some years ago
um so basically
or or try to kind of give you an
intuitions like how what I understand
about this and um here and then please
like feel free to jump in
um right so basically like this this
sort of Venn diagram is characterizing
all the um
like any of uh conjective queries
so we have we
um
we have some like non-hierarchical
queries they're not known to be Sharpie
hard and also some
um hierarchical ones
that's
um also
don't I don't exactly know the the um
intuition for this
um how to how to characterize this
but basically we um we have this you
know dichotomy hearing from from
um Dan's paper that shows that
um
we have this separation within the
hierarchical queries that's going to be
you know polynomial time and then
everything outside being Sharpie hard
and when you think about
um database query evaluation one way to
also
um evaluate them is actually compile
them two circuits right like around the
compilative circuits and then evaluate
the queries using circuit evaluation
so in in that case we want we care about
you know the size of the circuits uh
size of the resulting compiled circuits
right
so basically I think I also thought this
was interesting that some like inversion
free or like the inversion free
for diversion free queries
um obdds and STDs are essentially
equally succinct
and then we also have
this result showing that some subset of
these uh or polynomial time computable
queries can actually be compiled into a
polynomial size fpdd or decision dnf
um at this point I think this was a
open question I don't know if this is
still true or that that line is still
open and I don't think anybody worked on
it but I want to mention that Miguel
Monet over here made a significant
progress by showing that q9 and qw uh
those they can be captured by polynomial
size uh
um ddn and Fs plus plus
which I actually shortened to and call
them TDS
it's a major result so acute here you
can probably give us an impromptu talk
one of these days
yeah please please do oh
[Music]
okay anything more
um you want to add
sure
um all right so
I mentioned earlier
um about you know how it is this uh
characterization of trackability by the
destructive property is actually the
right one and specifically kind of how
we've characterized you know the problem
with the queries
um and and some properties that we
mentioned will actually give you uh
tractable inference for those particular
queries
the the question here really is um
we've shown that for example to compute
marginals we need or we want to have
smoothness and decomposability on
probabilistic circuits
so this is showing that these are
um sufficient conditions right so now
the question is
um are they actually are they actually
necessary can you compute marginals
without having you know either of those
properties
um so the answer in this case is
actually yes so note that I particularly
said
um for inference by this feed forward
evaluation they're necessary
um of course if you have decomposability
you can
um
you can always smooth the circuit
um not in linear time but still in
polynomial time so
it means they're not smoothness is
technically not necessary for hold time
uh compilation or part-time evaluation
but it's still you know we actually show
that it's necessary if you want to
essentially
compute marginal by this single feed
forward evaluation
and
um I think you can show this pretty
easily by showing that without uh
decomposability you cannot you know
decompose integrals uh downward and and
you can actually
um
actually uh make a pretty simple counter
example right
um so the other classes
um the other class of
Cruise resolver was map which we said
that with determinism and
decomposability we can compute map also
by just a single feedword evaluation by
just
switching sums to Max nodes
so in this case
um
we could said that you need the
decomposability and determinism we kind
of lied slightly that decomposability is
not necessary in this case so it's a
sufficient condition but not actually
unnecessary
condition
and there is actually a slightly weaker
condition called consistency or with the
composability which I think is honestly
a better name that actually suffices
right so
if we have determinism and consistency
we can also um compute Now attractively
by just this single feed forward
evaluation
so um what is actually consistency
so um we say a circuit is
consistent if for every product node
if any uh any of its children share a
variable
then that variable has to appear in in
just a single node in a shared Leaf node
so this is an example of a consistent
circuit
this is an inconsistent circuit because
you have variable X2 appearing in both
sides of this product node but in two
different Leaf nodes
so if you think in terms of a logical
circuit this is basically saying if you
have a shared variable it needs to be
either a positive literal in both cases
or negative literal in both cases
so of course um decomposability always
implies consistency if you don't have
any shared variables between inputs to a
product node there's no additional
um additional check you need to do so
this makes it a weaker property than
decomposability so for logical seconds
is it is it something more complicating
I'm just saying that since it will
appear with the same
negative value
[Music]
it is
so if you have let me try to remember so
I'll actually I actually
um
in a few slides down I can actually show
you in cases where you can turn up the
system
by just essentially if it's how it works
by factoring it out
right
um so why why is uh consistency actually
uh sufficient format just kind of going
quickly here for determinism
um it's the same as before so for
consistency
um
to break straight down this mass of
products into a smaller operator or a
smaller um
a combination of queries
how we used decomposability was just
saying that
um because this is a product of two
um like independent functions that
they're depending on this joints and the
variables you can just optimize on each
set of variables like independently okay
here they will have some they can have
some shared variables
but you can still
um maximize them independently because
any solution
um you sort of any assignment you get uh
for as a result of the maximization on
the shared variables they have to be the
same assignment because they appear on
through the same Leaf node foreign
independently when you have only only
consistency but not decomposability
so why why does this matter the fact
that you know um
the fact that decomposability is
actually not necessary
um because of this sort of succinctness
of course right so if the question is if
you
only cared about map and not marginal
do you gain anything by
um
by enforcing consistency instead of the
strong stronger properties which is uh
decomposability
so to kind of um
walk you through this sort of success
map involving these two classes of or
just two families of models
so we already essentially saw that uh
turning a circuit deterministic is hard
meaning we have
um
that you know smooth and decomputable
circuits are strictly more succinct than
uh deterministic ones
and there's actually a polynomial time
you know
algorithm to um
turn smooth and consistent circuit into
smooth and decomposable ones
and this is basically where you can you
know pull out a shared variable to the
Top If you have smoothness
the question is for the um remaining
remaining edges here
first
um
looking at this example of
William formula so
here let me
here we have these Z variables marked
with some you know I J uh subscript
basically these ones all come from a set
of variables in X and they might have
some you know um
the shared variables so so this or or if
this thumbnail is is not uh smooth
because these two
um various variables may be different
maybe some different variables within X
um it is deterministic because we we
have this product with uh Y and not y
variables
and also
um it is consistent because in in this
giant product all the shared
um
yeah all the um
shared variables are all have to be like
within X here right so so all of these Z
variables might be X and they may be
shared but they always appear as
positive literals
so um
there is this um kind of variant of of
um
sharp at least more
I think this was a counting like a
variant of counting like
Set uh two sets yeah problems that
basically
um
because this problem
um Counting this
um
problem is hard we can show that you we
can't take this kind of circuit and then
um compute marginal on it meaning we
can't really turn it into a circuit that
is decomposable
so that gives us
this direction
that um
turning deterministic and consistent
circuits into a decomposable one is is
hard
and then we actually
have the other results so if you're
starting with a um
if you're starting with a circuit where
you can compute marginals right so if
the circuit is
um
representing for example a knife base
distribution
where we can compute margins easily
on this kind of circuit Computing
um well
so so on this Knight base distribution
if we marginalize out the class variable
that's
still a smooth and decomposable circuit
but then if we try to perform map on
this circuit that corresponds to solving
marginal map on this starting line base
distribution between no is actually MP
heart as was hinted earlier meaning
we get this result that between this uh
families of models that can compute map
and and the one that we can uh that can
compute marginals neither is uh strictly
more succinct than the other
basically
um kind of the takeaway is that if you
care about one query but not the other
you want to be careful in in choosing
which properties you um you actually
enforce
and of course
there's a lot of you know families of
circuits that we can characterize by
these properties
um so you want to kind of complete the
map and I kind of presented
um this example like a workshop and then
and then soon
um I think
uh Stefan and and Alexi who've published
this paper that was kind of completing
um that picture like this with this nice
hyper Coupe showing relations between uh
uh circus families so these are like
arithmetic
circuits um with with uh positive
weights and here um just just as a
legend WD is is referring to a weak
decomposability which I've been
referring to as consistency so far
right so so hidden here is is
kind of this uh 2D
um result saw but they actually could
have completed the picture
and also
um what was interesting is they also
studied kind of the succinctness map
between between
um positive circuits which is also
unfortunately kind of a confusing name
but basically these are circuits that
are guaranteed to have non-negative
output but or still allowed some
negative weights
right so so in this case that's more
General like what is the um
what's the um implication on uncircuit
sizes you have by
imposing some structural properties and
there's actually still some sort of uh
open questions there
of course there's also the question of
reflexiveness between
um circuits with positive weights and in
circuits that are allowed to have
negative weights
um but still have to be positive in the
output
um I think in in this paper they also
showed that in in the case of if you
have determinism they're basically
equally succinct
but um otherwise I think there's some
um sub families where they were able to
show some separation but also still kind
of open edges in that domain
okay
so hopefully
um kind of answer some some of your
questions on you know how are the
circuit size and collectibility related
specifically in terms of the
tructibility characterized by those
circuit properties
um so next
um
what I want to talk about is
some of the more sort of advanced
reasoning algorithms you have and how we
can actually
um use them in some some exciting
applications
okay so
um
so here so
what we've seen so far in terms of
tractable inference algorithms and
coming up with those uh influence
algorithms were given some query
we're trying to identify some structural
properties that would let you compute
the query for example in in feed forward
evaluation or some dynamic programming
algorithm right and given a new query
you you'd have to go and you know find
um again what what's going to be the
appropriate necessary and sufficient
conditions for that particular new query
um
in in this
um work from a couple years ago so what
we wanted to
ask was given a arbitrary class of
queries is there a way to more
systematically find what the um
what the sufficient and necessary
properties are for for that class of
query and come up with a inference
algorithm
reusing as much of sort of the existing
um existing algorithms and intuitions we
have
okay
so the approach here is going to be kind
of um
characterizing queries as compositions
of some simple operators
so these are the the
um ones that we focused on I think
kind of do the um intro of this and then
we can continue after the the break so
The Operators we looked at were the
simple kind of sums and products of
circuits and also taking for example uh
Power or like logarithm
of the function represented by the
circuits and these are just these
operators already cover a lot of
diversions and and particular
information theory of the questions you
could ask
so the view is going to be
um
taking taking a query of interest and
then viewing it as a pipeline of these
operators that you know take in circuits
do some operation output another circuit
and and have a whole pipeline that way
um so to actually use a concrete example
let's say
we're trying to compute a chailed
averages between two uh distributions
so here let's assume that that both the
distributions are given to us as
probabilistic circuits
so looking at this you know definition
of KL Divergence we can see that
here the Opera operators that's going to
be involved are
for example we start by you know taking
a quotient or dividing
probability given by P with the
probability given by Q circuit so that's
one operator
now assume we can actually do this and
represent the result of that as another
circuit
you can see that okay after that what we
want to do is take a logarithm of this
output you know intermediate circuit
and imagine we could also you know we
can again output this uh result of the
logarithm as another circuit
take a product of this with the initial
circuit p
and if this result
um is a circuit that lets us oops that
lets us compute marginals basically
arbitrary integrals then you can just
take this compute the integral and that
gives us a kale Divergence of the
starting two circuits okay
and what's nice about this is we can
once we have these operators on the
circuits we can reuse them okay
so from before we use the product and
algorithm just taking those two we can
also compute cross entropy between uh
two circuits
so in Cross entropy what we have is take
a log log of one circuit take the
product of it with
the original inputs and then take um and
then compute the integral over it
we can do this
um you can so basically combine these
operators in such a way to compute
different queries okay
um
I think I can do a couple more slides so
um to kind of characterize when we can
perform this kind of uh operators on on
circuits let me just introduce another
property uh called compatibility so this
is kind of our
um first property that's going to be
defined in terms of pairs of search kits
in terms of uh two circuits so we'll say
two probabilistic circuits are
compatible
if they have the same hierarchical scope
partitioning meaning
um
you can essentially think of this as you
know what we said earlier which was
structure decomposable but with the same
V3
and and compatibility kind of slightly
generalizes that
um for instance to not require uh to
conform to a binary V3
but kind of intuitively you can you can
think of them as
two circuits that conform to the same V3
this is an example of a compatible
a pair of circuits this one is not
compatible because you can see that you
know this product node
um doesn't have the same decomposition
as
these two are also product nodes at the
very top
so with this new property if we have you
know two circuits that are compatible
and also
um smooth then you can actually
compute the product of those two
basically like multiplying two
distributions
and then I'll put the results as another
circuit
um that's again smoothly composable and
also compatible with both of the input
circuits
and the fact that we can characterize
what properties will have on the output
is important because next or what we
want to do next is actually compose
these operators right so we want we want
to be able to say okay after I do this
operations we have properties X Y and Z
so that I can apply another operator
after that
so we'll stop here and then we can uh
let's continue after the break
okay
any pressing questions
foreign
so
okay coffee time